sehr viele deutsche youtuber haben
videos zu meiner kürzlich erschienenen
pizza hochgeladen und ich habe mir
gedacht ich reagiere heute mal auf ein
paar ich glaube genauso ist wirklich am
siebzehnten zehnter jeder aufgewacht da
gibt es keine ausnahme
das war nicht meine pizza aber es ist
auch eine margarita von gustavo gusto
also lassen wir es mal durchgehen muss
ich dir recht geben also ich feiere
dünnem boden auch mega ich hasse pizzen
die so einen richtig dicken boden haben
und dafür weniger belag und keine ahnung
was also hey wir sind derselben meinung
geist das ist eine straße gab es draußen
war der fall hat mich auch ein bruder
was geht auch nicht der video eigentlich
auch ganz neues
ja wir gucken wir weiter hat vor
entscheiden sich aus gesagt wie sieht
einfach ganz anders aus wie eine chance
die polizei
was los ihr scheiß hater alter ist ein
vollidiot der boden auch die ist also
das habe ich auch vor ort in den
kommentaren gelesen dass einerseits
leute das total feiern dass die pizza so
dünn ist und ich meine wenn ihr mal
richtig geil pizza essen war irgendwo
zum beispiel den besten leben in köln
die opel zu machen da sind die pizzen
aber andere leute meinen die ist voll
dünnen und finden dass kaka also ich
weiß nicht wie man so was kranke finden
kann aber geschmäcker sind ja
unterschieden ich habe jetzt so kurz
gesagt dass wir dafür nun gut danke auf
jeden fall für euro props und auch schön
dass euch die pizza schmeckt und ja
natürlich schmeckt eine richtig geile
pizza im laden noch mal geil aber es ist
halt eine tiefkühlpizza und eine richtig
geile pizza im laden kostet noch über 10
euro das hast du jetzt gesagt jeder soll
das essen was er mag
[Musik]
das ist jetzt glaube ich sein kollege
der die pizza auch noch probiert hat er
gerade aus der schule wieder kamen also
auch an dich heißt dass sie die aus
schmeckt halt viele tiefkühlpizza
geschmeckt hat einfach wie eine
tiefkühlpizza und die halt als alter
freund mich richtig dass das ihr denkt
dass andere pizzen dagegen müll sind
also ja freut mich so etwas anzuschauen
aber meine damen und herren ich würde
sagen wir machen direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten youtuber der auch meine witze
probiert hat
ich muss sagen dein introns am ist sehr
sehr geil ich muss sagen die tun wird
einfach mal da unten in den backofen
genau das sollte man nämlich auch in
nativ gewitter machen also eins muss man
wirklich sagen
sieht wirklich damit geil aber es ist
einfach ganz besonders lecker da muss
man halt wirklich mal darauf achten wenn
man sich nicht nur eine loop capital
gekauft hat sondern vielleicht zwei oder
drei oder so und ihr macht die dann euch
zusammen mit freunden oder so vergleicht
mal die pizzen also ich finde bei
anderen pc-herstellern ich will jetzt
keine marken nennen aber da sieht jede
pizza wirklich gleich aus egal wie man
sich die macht und ich finde wirklich
wenn man sich meine pizza macht die
sieht immer anders aus was natürlich
auch schlecht sein kann weil das dann
sein kann
die von dem ein bisschen schöner von dem
anderen her nicht so schön aber ich
finde es einfach geil dass jede pizza
ist ein unikat so dahin ist übrigens der
karton von der pizza und ich habe meinen
merchandise an freunde deswegen steht
wieder werbevideo mann
ich schreibe jetzt immer werbevideo da
hin weil ich trag vorläufig meinen merge
und immer als die pizza hintergrund also
meine videos werden nicht bezahlt von
ihm im unternehmen oder so aber ich will
das jetzt ja alles transparent halten
die kennt die shop adresse aber wir
schauen jetzt mal wie ihm so die pizza
schmeckt ich würde sagen da kommen auch
schon zusammen fazit und zwar die pizza
schmeckt wirklich gut ich wirklich sagen
kann auch wirklich mit so einer ganz
normalen pc wirklich mithalten weil sie
ist echt verdammt großen schmeckt auch
wirklich gutes muss man wirklich schon
sagen junge danke dir ja er sagt sogar
dass die pizza mit einer pizzeria pizza
mithalten kann
junge
welcher pizzeria kriegt ihr ne geile
pizza für unter vier euro jetzt mal no
joke jedoch verstehe ich eine
kleinigkeit nicht und zwar was hat das
genau jetzt bekommen kräfte zu tun also
irgendwie ist mit ist bis jetzt nicht
ganz zum schluss nicht geworden außer
der sticker der drin war da gebe ich dir
auf jeden fall ein bisschen recht das
ist ein kommentar den ich auch relativ
häufig bekommen habe hey luca was hat
denn so eine stinknormale magath
eigentlich mit ihr zu tun habe ich euch
ja auch schon hier relativ häufig gesagt
und zwar wollte ich erste pizza machen
wo irgend wie das smiley mit integriert
ist oder so allerdings kosten maschinen
die das wirklich in der salami stand
sind können oder keine ahnung was im
hohen hohen sechsstelligen bereich
deswegen wollte ich halt erstmal
allgemeinen testen ob seine pizza bei
euch überhaupt gut ankommt ob ihr sowas
feiert und ja also krank die jetzige
version der luca pizza hut auf jeden
fall nur quasi mein eigenes design den
sticker mit drin das verpackungs die
möglichkeiten den ans theater zu nutzen
und so weiter und so fort aber wenn ich
demnächst die zweite besser machen
sollte dann ja werde ich da mehr mich
selbst rein integrieren also
wir reagieren jetzt auf die nächsten
youtube so leid das zeug für den doppel
upload aber heute bringt glück hat seine
neue witze raus und natürlich lassen
sich nehmen ich habe ihn wirklich erst
durch das video entdeckt was hat über
meine pizza gemacht hat aber er macht
ultra keine videos schaut auf jeden fall
mal bei ihm vorbei und das video von ihm
habe ich halt nicht eben wie gesehen
weil mir das zugeschickt wurde oder
keine ahnung was sondern er war einfach
platz vier in den trends egal sein video
hat gerade irgendwie 600.000 aufruf oder
irgendwie so auf jeden fall ultra krank
wie das video über meine pizza bei ihm
abgegangen ist
aber ich würde sagen wir schauen uns das
mal an das ist die richtige ja was ich
denke ja ich bin ein kontrollfreak
endlich tut obolus ist eigentlich war
die verpasste bitten verstören heute ich
schlimm ist die verpackung ist sogar so
groß fünf fucking rucksack alter john
ford mit rocking luca pizza mann sofort
danach war ich noch die szene denn ich
habe überall oder besser gesagt meine
frau hatten heute morgen über angerufen
welchen riebel dieses verdammte pizza
hier postet ich hab gedacht das ist auch
woanders gibt aber nicht meinen riese
daneben gibt es diese pizza vermutlich
gibt es tatsächlich wirklich nun aber
das habe ich sehr oft geschrieben
bekommen unfassbar viele leute haben
sich bei mir darüber beschwert dass es
die pizza nicht in jedem rewe center
gibt und nicht in jedem rewe supermarkt
und nicht im je medica und keine ahnung
was leute die pizza war in vielen
märkten wirklich direkt ausverkauft
direkt am morgen weil die märkte halt
nicht wussten ok dass ein youtube eine
pizza wieviel bestellen wir vielleicht
nur 300 stück oder so und die bahn halt
dann relativ schnell weg oder sie haben
auch tatsächlich gar nichts bestellt die
supermärkte haben sich halt nicht
gedacht dass da jetzt so viele von euch
von der lukb uhr ein gestürmt kommen und
sich quasi pizza kaufen also wie schon
im block vor ein paar tagen gesagt ihr
habt sogar die kundenhotline von rewe
zentral deutschland komplett gesprengt
an diesem morgen also es tut mir leid
dass einige wahrscheinlich zu märkten
gefahren sind wo ist die pizza dann
nicht mehr gab oder die dienen doch
nicht bestellt haben oder irgendwie so
das tut mir unfassbar leider aber
vielleicht könnt ihr euch ja als
community untereinander austauschen also
wenn jemand jetzt in den kommentaren
fragt haye gibt es dann
irgendwann er keine ahnung stuttgart
oder so dass dann vielleicht jemand
anderes aus stuttgart ihm antwortet und
sagt hey ja hier noch nie er gibt die
bei dem revier der hatte heute morgen
noch welche oder so dass ihr euch da so
ein bisschen untereinander vernetzt weil
man bekommt nicht vor den supermärkten
listen welcher rewe sich welches produkt
bestellt weil das unglaublich viel
aufwand wäre aber wir schauen zwar
weiter sein video an kohlenhydraten 118
140 gramm man braucht kein fucking jim
mehr alter einfach die pizza essen 40
gramm pro pizza mann geküsst und sehen
ob ich den sticker habe freunde habe ich
den sticker habe ich den guten stücken
taxi km du hast den taktiker leider
schon riesen pizza größer weil meine
regel geht es hier richtig kleine pizzen
die man drei stück bekommt und richtig
eklig schmecken alter freunde ich war
mit max vor ein paar tagen einkaufen im
supermarkt und wir haben da diese pizza
gesehen
von ich ich möchte mag jetzt ich sagen
auf jeden fall war das von karton oder
waren drei so kleine pizza margherita
übereinander drin für irgendwie zwei
euro fünfzig oder irgendwie so und ich
habe mir die mal gekauft und wollte aber
kein video darüber machen weil ich die
mag nicht schlecht machen wollte und
habe sie hat einfach gegessen und nach
ein paar bissen hatte ich keinen bock
mehr darauf mann soll wirklich nur
produkte machen und videos machen und
allgemeinen ursachen kreieren und nur
sachen tun die einem wirklich spaß
machen und wo man doch wirklich voll
hinter steht und hinterm einer pizza
stehe ich voll hinter und ich bin ganz
ehrlich das mache ich lieber eine pizza
die größer ist und drei euro 79 kostet
als sowas zu drei pizzen die alle
scheiße schmecken und asch kleinen aber
gut wir schauen weiter also lieber noch
hast du schuld ist mir eine erklärung
warum einer pizza margherita ein stück
thiemel ist leidig weiter an gustavo
gusto das kann wirklich nicht sagen okay
ich muss schon zugeben dass ich schon
live
danke dir kolleg man kann das einfach
benutzen einfach so erscheinen um
arbeitet dürfte es halt nicht durchkommt
ok haben löcher allerdings nicht zu sehr
scharf bis dann schafft es nicht mal den
ersten karton durch zu boden ist schon
mal sehr gut er ist tatsächlich mit
einer der ersten die ich wirklich
gesehen habe die auch den karton als
pizza teller benutzt haben weil freunde
also ich hab das schon ernst gemeint ich
habe das auch extra so häufig gesagt
dass die pizza wirklich riesig ist die
passt auf keinen handelsüblichen teller
den ihr so manchmal kaufen könnt benutzt
bitte wirklich den karton als teller
also da spart ihr das spülen nachher
oder den trams auch in die spülmaschine
zu räumen oder so und der geht wirklich
nicht kaputt also ich bin auch mit
meinem pizzaschneider da drüber gefahren
hab der im video vor ein paar tagen
gesehen und da ist auch nichts passiert
noch mal alles muss wirklich zugeben die
pizza schmeckt wirklich sehr sehen danke
auf jeden fall auch für dein video
tutorial ist ich finde auch mega hits
wie dein video abgegangen ist also jetzt
gerade wo ich das video hier aufnehmen
ist der 19
du bist immer noch in den trends bei mir
platz 6 oder so also mega geil und ich
find's schön dass sie die pizza schmeckt
und meine damen und herren ihr wisst ja
dass ich bei diesem event war wo ich am
17.10
die blitzer verteilt habe vor dem rewe
wo ich ja auch block zu gemacht habe
[Musik]
auf jeden fall habt ihr glaube ich
mitbekommen dass max nicht dabei war
dass apple nicht dabei war also youtube
kollegen von mir waren nicht dabei
freunde von mir war nicht dabei war
wirklich nur somit management mit dabei
die leute von gustav august und von
prosieben live singen weil ich wollte
das so unter uns halten so ein bisschen
familien mäßig ich nehme mir die zeit
gibt jedem persönlich die pizza wir
können uns kurz unterhalten können
bilder machen andererseits versuche ich
natürlich auch so viele leute wie
möglich irgendwie glücklich zu machen
deswegen habe ich ja keinen anderen
youtuber irgendwie eingeladen oder
gesagt hey komm doch auch gern herum
sondern ich dachte wirklich okay ich und
ihr und ich kann mich von der pizza
überzeugen kann euch zeigen hey probiert
sie einfach das war wirklich nur so eine
aktion hey probiert die pizza kostenlos
falls ihr sagt sie ist zu teuer oder ihr
wollte erst mal probieren das war
wirklich also im man muss nichts
bezahlen und konnte mich treffen und man
konnte pizzaessen die idee fahren wir
halt ganz cool haben wir dann ja auch
umgesetzt hat ja auch ultra viel spaß
gemacht so wie ich das jetzt in den
resonanzen mitbekommen habe und wir
haben uns halt mit der security mit dem
sicherheitsdienst so ein konzept
überlegt wie wir das alles machen mit
den absperrungen wie viele leute auf dem
parkplatz fahren dürfen und dann kam ein
anderer großer youtuber dmc meine damen
und herren lk felix laden er hat auf
youtube gerade hier können wir kurz 3,15
millionen abonnenten walter 3 millionen
3 millionen ist eine übels kranke zahl
wie viele kann jeder in deutschland um
über drei millionen muss man sich nur
vorstellen ist ja echt heftig ich wusste
nicht dass der wirklich so fucking viele
abonnenten hat aber back to topic
den hat auch ein video zu der pizza
gemacht und da schauen wir einfach mal
zusammen rein hier vorne ist der super
so richtig wie er sich jetzt schon mal
felix mini hatte der nicht immer so
krasse karten am start eigentlich sollte
morgen war noch nicht ob man schade
dachte ich könnte in der mini community
begrüßen also felix ist jetzt hier mit
dem mini von ich weiß nicht
wahrscheinlich dem von seiner freundin
oder so auf den tag mehr zeit vor
gefahren wo wir das fantreffen
veranstaltet hatten die haben den ganzen
platz in beschlag genommen
danke danke freut mich dass ihr das
design gefällt nur jetzt kommen wir
wirklich dazu was mich persönlich in dem
moment so ein bisschen abgefuckt hat
sage ich ganz ehrlich jena ist dann zu
mir gekommen wo ich die pizza ausgeteilt
habe was ich an sich eine coole gäste
fand aber wenn ein youtube mit 3,1 aber
nett drei 3,1 3,1 abonnenten wenn ein so
großer youtuber natürlich dahin kommt
dann ist es natürlich klar dass auch
einige von den leuten die wegen mir da
waren auch ihn kennen ihr habt gerade
gesehen ich war so ein bisschen
überrascht ihn zu sehen weil ich halt
wie gesagt eigentlich keinen so erwartet
hatte beziehungsweise eingeladen hatte
und war auch ehrlich gesagt in dem
moment ein bisschen ich möchte
eigentlich alle irgendwie glücklich
machen so dass so viele leute wie
möglich mich treffen können und das hat
die situation so ein bisschen kaputt
gemacht ihr seht schon hat das ganze
auch so ein bisschen verwundert warum er
da auf einmal aufgetaucht ist
ich möchte natürlich gut danke freut
mich dass du die pizza schmeckt die
person mit der felix ott geredet hat war
von dem security team was wir da am
start hatten und er war eigentlich dafür
zuständig dass bei mir die leute quasi
im geregelten abständen zu mir kommen in
dem quasi keine geschenke an packt ihr
in den kopf da hinten doch ein bisschen
dafür dass alles quasi gut und gesittet
abläuft und der musste sich dann halt
leider um felix kümmern weil felix dann
plötzlich da und bei mir fehlt der
anhaltende security personen das heißt
in dem zeitraum wo felix da war es beim
yaris schleppend vorangegangen und das
hat alles nicht so gut funktioniert also
ich finde ich bin ganz ehrlich ich fand
die geste cool felix da war das also das
war so ein bisschen blöd auch jetzt
gerade auch noch mal gesehen der
security beamte musste dann neben felix
herlaufen und ihn quasi raus los dass
dort keine leute noch irgend wie vor dem
auto her gelaufen sind so oder so also
das hat die also dadurch felix dass ihr
gekommen seid das hat die situation so
ein bisschen na ja so ein bisschen
durcheinander gebracht oder so aber
versteht mich nicht falsch das war schon
cool dachte ich schon dass viele leute
da sie aber nicht so viele leute ja das
ist mehr als ein video data waren es ist
schon krass und ist mir voll unangenehm
zum einen luca gegenüber weil das so
sein ding hier alles easy war halt nur
in dem moment ein bisschen stressig dann
für alle beteiligten ich würde nicht
sagen dass ich die beste bin ich meinem
leben vergessen
meine fresse alter durch marina und sein
kater beziehungsweise kameramann philipp
wollten dann noch mal in den rewe
reingehen und sich die pizza kaufen
beziehungsweise philipp weil dieser
nicht reingehen wollte wegen den ganzen
zuschauern vorn ist ja auch verständlich
allerdings weit auseinander dort
ausverkauft und hier jetzt die szene
ok also hier müssen eigentlich ihr seht
und einander marken ist natürlich dass
da aber die lücke pizza ist ausdruck
kommt anscheinend und dann haben sie die
pizza von abonnenten von mir abgekauft
wollt ihr im blog sein und vielleicht
eine von den pizzen verkaufen weil es
gibt keinen geworfen in dem blog vor
allem auch hier die personen die dort
gezeigt wurde ehrenmann alter hier er
hier
du bist krass alter was mein mann muss
fucking luke crew member also wir geben
euch im 15 jetzt kommen wir zur nächsten
sache die mich ein wenig aufgeregt hat
an dem video von felix und zwar haben
sie halt zuschauer und die pizza für
fünf euro abgekauft was natürlich
vollkommen in ordnung ist weil die
zuschauer gesagt haben herr ja klar
durch die machen allerdings stand im
titel von denen das video halt youtuber
pizza für fünf euro gekauft an sich ist
das richtig ihr seid zu leuten gegangen
und habe den meine pizza für fünf euro
abgekauft allerdings wenn sich leute das
video nur bis zur hälfte angucken
kriegen die hat nicht diese szene mit
und denken hey dieser youtuber verkauft
seine pizza für fünf euro ich finde man
hätte den titel anders wählen können wie
beispielsweise wir probieren lukas pizza
oder wird es lukas mit seinem ufo oder
youtube pizza von fan gekauft oder so
aber das mit fünf euro es kommt so rüber
als wenn meine pizza fünf euro kostet
natürlich wird das preisschild von der
pizza im revier im video von philipp
gezeigt allerdings für eine sekunde und
der titel ist als dauerhafter also das
fand ich so ein bisschen mit leading
aber wir schauen uns das video mal
weiter an
diese mikrowelle hier diesen die hat
aber eine grillfunktion mitgebracht und
hoffe dass wir da machen können du
möchtest die pizza mit einer mikrowelle
machen mit einer mikrowelle mit grill
funktionen junge teuerste pc-welt erste
pizza der welt
ja definitiv felix scheiße oder discos
basilikum stimmt ja es ist nicht da aber
warum ist auf der verpackung 30 glaube
felix will darauf anspielen dass hier
auf der verpackung hier basilikum drauf
ist und ja auch so ein bisschen
naja auf der pizza verpackung bin auch
ich hinten drauf bin ich in der
verpackung also laut felix hätten wir
dann wohl das basilikum mit auf die
pizza legen sollen das heißt das
basilikum wer dann tiefgefroren und du
hättest die pizza mit basilikum drauf in
den ofen entschuldigung in der novelle
hier diesen schieben müssen und dann
wäre das basilikum was man eigentlich am
ende einer pizza kalt und frisch oben
drauflegt werden unfassbar heiß also ich
kann gerne für dich noch mal eine eigene
pizza backen mit basilikum obendrauf in
die ganze dann in einer mikrowelle
schieben aber das wird nicht schmecken
vier bis acht minuten als er das ist was
mit spannung drei vier bis acht minuten
ist eine spannbreite von vier minuten
felix ich kann ja auch mal beibringen
aber jetzt mal spaß beiseite wir haben
extra gesagt vier minuten weil wenn man
sie 4 minuten quasi drin hat dann ist er
halt noch so ein bisschen okay für die
leute die das jetzt nicht so knusprig
haben wollen und alt acht minuten dann
er okay das ist dan wie die lustige
leute dieses bisschen crosby haben
ich glaube ich weiß was ich meine ist
eine spannweite von 4 minuten felix und
auch für die verpackung haben uns
insbesondere einfach decke auf weiß
umklappen und fähig sein pizza teller
und jetzt das ist jetzt höher
wir haben hier hinten einen rein gemacht
und hier kannst du falls sie diese
lasche dann rein stecken so dass das
quasi festhält und dann hast zu halten
gesicherten boden kannst du auf deine
pizza essen und schneiden also ich fand
ein bisschen blöd wie das dargestellt
wurde weil wenn man sich informiert
hätte dann wüsste man dass da hinten
auch beim stoff ist oder wenn man sich
überhaupt nur die verpackung angeguckt
hätte aber ich kann er das gerne zeigen
felix ja das hat so eine heiße pizza
halt ansicht dass sie heißes
normalerweise lehrern kinder aus
hier ist es nicht der fall ist was
draufsteht wirklich auf der verpackung
gewesen als silikon darauf streuen
mainz oregano glaube ich
basilikum sind diese kleinen blättchen
ich mag ich eigentlich nicht schlecht
aber ultraläufer danke ich find's schön
dass ihr die pizza schmeckt er ich kann
ja auch gern mal welches uwe
vorbeibringen labbrig liegt glaube ich
an der mikrowelle mit grill funktion das
heute glocken haben weil die pizza
ausprobiert spaß beim zusehen ach das
war schon vom blog das war doch jetzt
eine zeitspanne von einer stunde
die sind ja zum revier gefahren und dann
und dann wieder aber gute freunde spaß
beiseite ich fand das video von den
nachrichten
ich finde es auch mega lights ist
eigentum gekommen seid die gäste waren
sich mega cool du hättest nur vielleicht
vorher bescheid sagen können dann hätten
wir so ein bisschen darauf angepasst bin
ich auf jeden fall ist es euch die pizza
auch geschmeckt hat nächstes mal dann
vielleicht im backofen zu hause machen
weil berufe habt ihr glaube ich keinen
das material wie auch schon zu mir auch
danke an die ganzen anderen leute hier
zu videos gemacht habe ich heute gesehen
dass sturm waffel auch im video dazu
hochgeladen hat aber das habe ich jetzt
nicht noch mehr eingekriegt und ich
werde schon der raw datei bei 45 minuten
ich will jetzt gar nicht mehr darum
herum schnacken meine freunde lassen
er wird euch das video gefeiert und
rodeo das ziel das war's jetzt hier vom
video hier können jetzt hier meinen
kanal abonnieren oder hier unten mal
einen schock aus checken jetzt findet
ihr zwei andere videos und wendischen
abonnenten zeit könnt ihr auch die
glocke klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]